[Musik]
was macht ihr immer lauter
wir sind eingebrochen das ist ein
richtiger weg oder ich danke blog machen
aber irgendwie waren da noch einmal jona
und maxim einer bruder von japan also
sieht so aus als würde jetzt noch machen
wir jetzt aus essen
bevor wir aber was essen gehen wollte
ich bin warum bist du dir jetzt meiner
wohnung in zu heiß ist also ich gehe mal
runter denn das nicht mehr so heiß wir
machen uns das so war ganz ganz kurz
spinnst du
wow diese kombination der mega gut aus
was das her
wir sind jetzt hier beim hessen
angekommen wie ich schon gesagt habe
da müssen wir jemanden grüßen
genau den abonniert kongress ist
übrigens gerade jonas kamera mit der ich
jetzt gerade beim essen aufnehmen
diese lockt jährlich kommen da kommt
auch schon die polizei direkt
also hier sind jetzt unsere enorm riefen
bürger angekommen
dort kommt verschlechtert
ich habe jetzt auch gegessen das hat ca
eine minute gedauert bis wir ein burger
aufgegessen hat aber es hat auf jeden
fall sehr lecker geschmeckt und dieser
stelle drückt
[Musik]
woran hat es gelegen hat man sich
nachher zu hause angekommen und werden
jetzt noch kurz ein bisschen weiß wo ich
muss kurz schaut man sich laut ich bin
gespannt ob diese noch steht
da steht doch fest
[Musik]
wir sind angekommen haben rein ihr seht
schon das ist nicht der einfluss ist es
halt wieder so mega geil das wetter wir
machen jetzt grad foto der 18 932
sido ich kann den dom gar nicht richtig
sehen was hast du das fernrohr und
spannend genug
naja ist ja alles aus ist ja schön dass
irgendjemand grüßen abonniert congo
after work
ich möchte grüßen der luke auf instagram
okay da ist das ist privatgrundstück
tutorial cherry oder steht hinter dem
schilden aus dem schild steht wie fette
welt ich habe ich halt wirklich von was
für leute nicht jungen geben wenn ich
mein alter was tut ihr mann
du bist nicht nämlich dann sind
die halbe
[Musik]
der plan jetzt gerade ist dass wir ja
und ja hallo frau schwer
der plan ist auf jeden fall dass die svp
vor schmerzen damit die vielleicht ein
bisschen grillfleisch kaufen können und
in der zwischenzeit fahren max und ich
zu marx und holt einen fernseher für
einen plan den wir gerade bis zu
verfolgen
ein mixtape leute bist du schon bereit
für die wahrscheinlich geilste aktion
des gesamtheit das ist eine typische
aktion das sieht man immer bei facebook
und sohn gegen welchen sprüchen so dass
man das mal machen muss und gibt machen
es halt einfach heute mal hier
der plan ist nämlich dass max gerade
seinen fernseher holt und dann wollten
wir den fernseher auf die terrasse
stellen und mario kart spielen draußen
auf der terrasse hinten sieht haben wir
einen fernseher
jetzt mache ich ja wieder angekommen und
wir selber noch ein paar sachen geholt
beim bäcker und so zum grillen wie sie
geschrieben das herum kommen kann hat er
bei mir haben wir tatsächlich heute mal
alle gegenüber lukas block noch
[Musik]
also der fernseher steht jetzt hier in
der ecke die switche einfach mal
dahinter gestellt und jetzt schauen ob
das ganze funktioniert wie mario kart
funktioniert auf dem fernseher was sagt
ihr dazu
dennoch nicht machen gerade quasi das
was so bei facebook immer gedacht und
gegen haye kinder draußen spielen über
den fernseher setzt sich nach draußen
hier vorne wird schön gespielt denkst du
so gesund so direkt nicht ganz raus zu
setzen
ihre teller sinne richtig toll aus ich
erstmal catch up trucks in die kamera
halte
wir haben so ein arschloch
die haben zu ende gegrillt und werden
und jetzt auch das weiter ergeben großen
touch mit anderen du bist die nächsten
aufnahmen werden im iphone sein weil ich
kein bock die kamera einfach super tag
das kommt gut voran
das kommt gut ja hier erwarte ich auch
sofort
es ist ein video die schlaufe war die
rede
das ist so weil ich bin der beste job
der welt
wollt ihr mich verarschen
das ist ein toller tag
hhv 23 durch
abonniert kongress
es geht heute um hochqualifizierten
ja
erster sechster luca müther punkt der
erste sechser lukas schott und bdh alle
sind nicht mehr am arbeiten kleine
tochter ist auch cool
wieso haben sie ja praktisch ganz
normaler tag in köln max läuft einfach
nachts ok just music service gerne was
ist das für ein laden ja ich verdiene
viel geld damit
da
wenn ihr auch einfach auf youtube com /
kontra fda könnte abonnieren könnt ihr
mal das video anschauen also dass die
platten feuerzeug am kiosk gekauft aber
du hast dich also warum das ist okay das
ist gerade auf toiletten max hatte die
glorreiche idee dort jetzt ein verdammt
guter ist wenn wir den film also eine
reaktion
[Gelächter]
hier gab gesehen und waren wir gar noch
kurzen aber bitte fragt euch nicht zu
selber unseren humor haben also wir sind
halt einfach alle komplett im arsch
gewesen deswegen freunde aber das war es
jetzt auch vom blog ich würde sagen es
euch gefallen da würde ich mich selber
live horizont sehen wir uns morgen das
video wieder juni
[Musik]